شوارع كابول وقد استباحها مدمن المخدرات
عدوا اليها بعد غياب لم يدوم سوى اشهر
معدوده في وضع النهار
يتعاطى المدمنون جرعات الافيون غير عابدين
بالمره وعلى مراه رجال الامن
الفقر والبطاله ومشكلات اخرى قادتني الى
الهيروين تلقيت العلاج مرتين لكن الاطباء
لا يهتمون بالمرضى فلا دوائه ولا غذاءه
ولا حتى ما
تحدد احصائيات رسميه عدد مدمني المخدرات
في افغانستان بين ثلاثه ملايين واربعه في
بلد يصل وعدد سكانها الى 40 مليون نسمه
بنسبه ادمان تتراوح بين عشره الى 15% من
سكان البلاد
هنا في مستشفيات ومراكز علاجيه ليس الوضع
افضل حالا رغم جهود من تبقى من اطباء
مختصين في علاج مدمنين فقد بعضهم ادميه
مشتاقين
اتطور رجوعا لم اتناول الغداء بل اغتات
على العشب نقف هنا ليل نهار دون اي مساعده
لم اجد احدا يقدم لنا شيئا ناكله السنا
بشرا هذا حالنا كما ترى اطلقوا سراحنا
نستطيع الحصول على الطعام في الخارج لماذا
نظلم هنا
المخدرات في افغانستان يعترفون ان الكارثه
اكبر من القدره على الاستيعاب معا انسحاب
المنظمات الدوليه وتوقف المساعدات التي
كانت تسخر لتمويل مراكز العلاج من الادمان
حقوق الانسان
عن حمايه البشريه
تبخرت امالها هؤلاء المدمنين في حياه
كريمه معا انبعاث دخان جرعات الافيون وليس
ثمه ما يوحي بان هذا الواقع الاليم سيتغير
على الاقل في المدى المنظور عوامل عده
تجعلوا افغانستان عاجزه عن مواجهه افه
المخدرات فهي ليست قادره على منع زراعه
الافيون ولا على الحد من انتشاره بين
الناس والى ان يتغير هذا الوضع ستظل شوارع
البلاد ملاذا للمدنين ناصر شديد الجزيره
كابل